Ok so we're at the national video game market, not him and here we have our 3D scanning, [Photobooth]
[we're] using technology to support the storytelling surrounding physical object
So what we have here is our third was here and the dSLR camera, and what we do
We're trying to make 3D scans of wargaming inches
Which is the example were using for the storytelling so what we do [is] we take a few images of our moms on our turntable?
So from all around from various Angles and stuff like that
And then we use those images through a bit of a magical [for] the [post] processing
procedure to create 3D models such as the one you see here where we have a
One-Inch to mention. Just like the gentleman back there and as you can see
just what images we have managed to make a
Detailed 3D model of it and [the] over here
We already have a gallery of quite a few of them, and we can just be embedded in any sort of known platform you can
Take those three miles and put them inside some other
Virtual experience you can just import them into Minecraft
All because of course there can be any size we can throw them into virtual reality you can walk around them see lemon
Life-sized and potentially even interact with him a bit of work, but you could potentially animate them as well
So quickly scan anything in this wretched because [I] put my car keys then you give me a scanner
But there are some limitations for example
We [so] it's not limited by sight really as long as you can get the images you can do it for example
[drones] a good excuse actually for me to get [drunk]
Have a few issues
So basically what the camera can't see you cannot scan so stop [at] this transplant is quite tricky
[there] are ways about it, but it's it's quite difficult and stuff at a shiny. I mean our brain is trained to disregard
Reflections [specular] stuff shininess our mindset we don't care about that
But the computer cannot do that so stuffed his shining directly translated internet. Just like so
[depending] on how you count the keys are for example, but it but there with the proper preparation and what if you think that doable?
Picture, [I] don't want to [show] [you] my card
I said well, technically I could 3D scan your car keys then 3D printing because yes, you could 3D print any [really]?
given Time [Africa] 3D printer
Now where's that key would work in your car
dependable computer
So I will
[as] your operation from the smartphone they just so smart [phone] [schultz] to the turntable that [talk] [to] the camera
So just get this order online
Is after you've written as always I don't know this was [off-the-shelf]. [I] mean one of the software and their methods are
Generally [bias] where we could we use off-the-shelf technology?
So this is a commercially available light box basically a very nice turntable
[but] it's actually our second version because we did make one entirely in-house out of whatever we could 3D print
[laser-cut] and various motors and stuff like that basically what them what [I] call the mark [10] [tablet]
Where you would place attack [mention] with an NFC chip in it into the photo booth and then it would immediately?
Start taking pictures of it however. It wasn't the best thing for [you] [to] scan [tense]
Why we went with a second more refined model that you see here, so this was basically the decision
as you can see
Turntable terms we get one picture every 10 degree
so [that] six images per rotation
And then all we [really] have to do is change the height on tripod get all the tangles on it
What does that give you that will give us quite a few images on average
We take about a hundred images [per] object depending if it's something that is the non convex and then you get different angles again
Whatever camera doesn't see they cannot make a model of so we try to make sure we get all the in part of the model
Then we throw that into us
[we're] and we align the images so each image needs to know where it is in comparison to the other one
so [will] ideally get something like that as you can clearly are three different heights around the model then that will create a
Sparse point cloud so basically
The between the images and we'll figure out interesting points on the model features and [others] pointed space
And once that is done
We go through a around more like the person [whoever] created dense point cloud that is basically the same thing
but way more points in space
And that almost looks like the object when it's done isn't a model herself 3D Polygon Model
But what it is is many many colored points in space following that of course we connect all the dots by literally?
[and] over the model
And then we make a crisp texture for it from the images again that basically makes it look like exactly what the object is so
For those heights and coloration that all just works out by various software
Or do you have to do it it depends if you're lucky and the model is quite detailed
Then we then it will pretty much to itself
But again like most things it's less its letter science to be honest and more little bit of anarchist
Depends on the model depends on the other pictures were taken and someone [are] great. So you always have to do a little bit of
[tweaking] manual work in quickly. So you can find our library of scan models online on our website
And as we go along with the particular national video game [market]. [we're] hoping to grow that from about [how] [many] [different] models
[we've] got now
200 or is known as we would like to bring to us here at the NBA hopefully once you got a nice big collection of
Models are just more gaming whatever people bring in
as best we can do whatever we want with these models, so
Maybe a walk through virtual reality gallery so use the HTC vive to just be able to walk through
[eventually] even interact with the models
put them up on the
The website each one with a little bit of bit of story about [reuters]. What is your goal? Storytelling angle, and then we'll see
So I omitted reality as it is all about tying [visual] content to the real world now. There are a few ways to do this
and
bearing and barring any specialist equipment what you can do is use optical techniques in this case which is